I'm ready to school you guys on
Philadelphia slang john-john man maybe a
tool of some sort the Philadelphia
version of like the outhouse isn't like
a joint like there's a couple different
ways you can use it one way you're like
hey come join my group and then like
this guy's my giant cuz I asked him to
join my grave you can use John with
anything you could be like you look dumb
John is hot come you shoe you know
that's a it look at that John drawing I
think of drawl I think of like a
Southern drawl but not somebody in
Philly this is something a good thing to
be doing
shorty so bad she's got your boy drawl
it over not probably not like drawing
taking too long to get ready like a girl
like she's drawin my mom was drawl and
asking me to get plane tickets for my
brother's wedding okay that sounds crazy
you have your first day of school outfit
ready to go it's on point your John is a
hunt point that's your school kill
outfit you're like cool when you're like
in a crowd but like by yourself you're
like a weirdo I'm sounds like a French
rapper and when I guess it's a French
rapper who moved to Philadelphia where
he was around 16 the Schuylkill is like
a road you take to get to Philly there's
traffic on the Schuylkill guard
we went to the art last weekend it was
crazy like when you're gonna go ham
we're gonna go are pirates come from
Philadelphia and are something that you
guys just say no man you didn't totally
waste your architecture degree it's hard
wit of it out no onions on a cheese
stage right oh that's without cheese
right the cheese owner but without uh
the ketchup you know I'm selling your
Philly cheesesteak uh son like that
I love all this slang I'm gonna try and
bring it to LA as John's cleanest [ __ ]
this is a clean John yeah